hey David is it fair not to let yang and
Tulsi speak during the debates it's not
I've talked about this we did a big
piece about this on the Monday show
where I explained I think there are too
many people on the stage I think there
should be five maybe six at this point
at the most based on who still has a
shot and how far into this thing we are
but if you make the stage you should get
roughly equal time I don't agree with
the network making editorial decisions
to say if you're polling better you will
get more time if you're polling poorly
you'll get less time except where we
want to do it differently and what we
saw in the fifth MSNBC to the fifth
debate which was on MSNBC last week was
that for example Andrew yang got
drastically less time then his polling
support would predict on the other hand
Pete Buddha judge was the biggest
beneficiary who got significantly more
time on screen talk time then his
polling would suggest so I do not think
it's fair for yang and Tulsi to speak
during the debates I'm no fan of Tulsi
Xand she has no shot but if she makes
the debate she should get the same
amount of time as everybody else andrew
yang I like I don't think he's going to
be the nominee I've interviewed him on
the program perfectly nice guy has good
ideas he should get the same amount of
time as everybody else if he has made
the debate if your argument is these
people don't really have a shot at
winning so it makes sense not to give
them much time well then they shouldn't
be on the stage if that's your you're
the DNC is running the election they
should have requirements for making the
debate stages that make sense
they should not be leaving it up to the
whims of for-profit media who may have
all sorts of different priorities
themselves MSNBC 10 trending towards the
sort of more establishment centrist
Democrats like Joe Biden Pete Budaj edge
they seem to sort of have reluctantly
made the call that if it is going to be
a more progressive candidate that wins
between Warren and Bernie they prefer
Warren's or they've been talking up
Warren over over Bernie and they've been
pert
unfair to Andrew yang referring to him
as John yang at least once if not more
they put a poll up on the screen a
couple weeks ago where they just ignored
the Andrew yang just wasn't on the
screen even though he was polling I
think in that poll 3 percent they had
people on screen who were polling to
just no explanation why John yang or as
he's actually called Andrew yang wasn't
there so I want to be really clear this
is not me being a yang yang uh I've said
I'm I'm a Bernie Warren guy but fair is
fair and if you make the stage you
should get the time that everybody else
gets it should be evenly distributed if
in a poll you're in sixth place
you shouldn't show one through five skip
person number six and then seven eight
nine whatever you should just put the
person up there that's it it's just not
fair and it's bizarre and it's strange
and to your question it's not fair to
let Andrew yang and Tulsi speak so
little when they have made the debate
stage based on the requirements that
have been put in place by the DNC we've
got a great bonus show for you today
where I will be facing off against
producer Pat Forde in a pre Thanksgiving
chess match what will happen there's
only one way to find out and that is to
check out the video version of today's
bonus show become a member at join
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access to the bonus show and
to today's chess match